and this trip is probably
the most comfortable trip i've taken in
terms of where we're staying
we're being taken care of trips
everywhere driver all of that stuff
but it's also been the most difficult
trip i've ever had to do in my life and
i mean i've traveled to many countries
poor and rich
nothing but a backpack on me and this
trip
um has been the most difficult i think
at every
building every place i've been to every
time i looked
the people who owned the spaces were
always white or light skinned the people
who managed the spaces were always white
alaskan
and then all the employees i saw were
dark skinned
and i saw this over and over again
and uh it got to me not because they're
white or they're necessarily
the skin tone but just seeing this
consistent pattern and it's also the way
the white and the light skin people talk
to dark-skinned people it's with
very little humanity very little
consideration yet here it's commonplace
so much so
that the black people accept it and so
here i am
performing i'm doing stand-up comedy i'm
getting paid and i look into the crowd
the only people that i can afford are
light-skinned and white people
right it's for the richer people in this
city and i'm like
is this what i got into the game for you
know we all seek out laughter in our
lives to get
alleviation from something but here i am
doing comedy for people
who have way less to be alleviated from
i want to make it easy for people at the
end of the day who
have an extremely difficult day i think
the breaking point for me was
one of our drivers a very kind haitian
man and one time we were being buried
somewhere
along with other comedians from other
countries
and i had to sit in the car and listen
to them mock his accent make fun of him
treat him
basically in a sub-human way for 40
minutes
i sit in the front and i'm livid i can't
i'm shaking like i've punched people for
way less and i'm sitting here continuing
myself because i'm a guest in this
country i don't know what the
consequences are if i act out
so i kept quiet and i think
uh easily one of the biggest regrets
i have because for my own self-interest
i kept quiet when i saw something that i
felt was unacceptable
and so i stayed up almost at night angry
and there are very few things in life
that make me angry you know even the
times i've cried i could honestly tell
you they're limited to
when my mother got sick when my father
passed away
and probably this because even though
i'm not of
a haitian background i didn't come to
this country
to be of another country i came here so
i can really embroil myself in what it
is
to be part of this culture and instead
what i find myself doing is i find
myself participating in a program
that for one way or another encourages
the oppression
of dark-skinned people it seems like
colorism is so entrenched in haitian
culture
that for me it's shocking it's shocking
because this is the same country that
you know cupid bulika we kicked out the
french the first
slave colony to become an independent
country
and so i've always looked up and i come
here and i see that
you know despite having spelled the
white people what i see is that the
people who are
at the top are white and light-skinned
people and you imagine what kind of
psychological damage that does
every day you walk and what you see is
the people being ordered around or your
people
whether you realize or not why you may
not be in physical bondage there is a
mental aspect to this that i feel is
very profound
you know people have been asking me why
haven't you taken pictures while you're
here why aren't you taking videos
because
i'm experiencing culture and what i'm
seeing is so troubling i couldn't
imagine putting that into videos and
images so then how am i supposed to
document this stuff and share it with
you guys because everyone wants to see
happy pictures
look at haiti it's so beautiful and
don't get me wrong this country has a
tremendous amount of beauty
but some of the issues that are
engulfing me as i'm sitting here
are so much more profound it would be
unjust and a lie
for me to get on social media and be
like look at me in front of this palm
beach
who gives a there are real problems
it's a life i don't say this stuff
because this is a reflection of what i'm
feeling
i've seen beautiful things i've seen all
of that but but the bigger
underlying thing that i'm seeing that is
just accepted by everyone that i can't
come to terms with
it's hard